[Music]
joining me today is a senior economist
for the institute of new economic
thinking whose research is focused on
economic biological and sociological
approaches to human welfare
dr. Pia Milani welcome to the Reuben
report it's great to be here it is I am
looking forward to talking to you
because we've gotten to know each other
a bit anyhow and and I enjoy your
company and you've we've had some
interesting discussion some of some
stuff that we agree on some that we
disagree on we're going to get into all
of that right here but before we get
into your work and economics and all the
heavy lifting of that you have an
interesting personal story childhood
growing up in India and and all that
stuff so so let's start there tell me a
little bit about your background okay
well I grew up in India
my mother is Jewish my father is Hindu
so I grew up Jewish within what I would
say is the closest thing to a
multicultural community that I have ever
seen
no growing up my best friend was Muslim
I'd go over to her home on Christmas to
decorate the Christmas tree my other
best friend was half Farsi half Hindu
and it really was an environment where
we didn't really even think so much
about our different backgrounds we just
all were and I didn't believe and
understand what anti-semitism was until
I left India and saw it in other
countries because it's perhaps the most
welcoming country to Jews and so it's
been really interesting for me to watch
the country change over the last 10 15
years where Hindu fundamentalism has
come in and taken over in a way that I
could never have imagined when I was
growing up there yeah it's interesting
because even though there has been a
historic Jewish community and idea for a
long long time people don't realize that
there are any Jews in India when you
tell people that they go west that come
on now a number of conversations I've
had where someone will sit across from
me in a completely straight face say I
can always recognize a Jew when I say
no idea that they're talking to right
right well somehow it's been associated
with like being white or something
although my my brother-in-law is half
Moroccan half Iraqi and used brown right
so my mother's community comes from
Syria Iraq the Middle East they call
them Sephardic Jews but technically them
its Rajee Jews and we actually had three
Jewish communities in India two of them
claim to be Lost Tribes so they've been
there since before the destruction of
the second temple and are much more
integrated in Indian lives and you know
speak the local languages and they have
their own synagogues Bombay has nine
synagogues so you know I grew up going
to one of the Sephardic synagogues they
have seven been Israeli synagogues and
you know it's the old Jewish joke where
that's the synagogue I pray at that's
the one I used to pray a prayer that's
the one I wouldn't be caught dead and
you know it really was sort of a divided
community and then we had this
horrendous attack in India a few years
ago where we had a group of 10 Pakistani
militants who landed on the shores of
Bombay and held the city hostage for I
don't know 48 hours and they went for
the Jewish community and they actually
went for the European Jewish community
that was living that was traveling
mostly through so we have a small Habad
group and they found a Habad house and
it was really horrendous but the one
effect that it did have was that it
brought the rest of the Indian Jewish
community together and we were there
very soon after that and it was so
interesting celebrating Hanukkah they
actually had this giant menorah in front
of the Gateway of India and huge police
presence but you know we were out there
and whatever little force we could
muster it's a really small community now
but we were all out there celebrating
Hanukkah together at the Gateway of
India yeah I remember when that happened
how many years ago was that roughly four
or five stopped five years ago yeah and
I remember reading articles about how it
wasn't just the the Jewish community
that came together but it was the entire
community that they were like we are not
going to stop being as multicultural as
as you're talking about you know in many
ways that was true I think
that's definitely something that came
out of that the flipside of that is that
Hindu fundamentalism has seen this very
ugly rise in India now and you know
we're now seeing what they're calling
cow debt where they're attacking Muslims
claiming that they're carrying beef or
they're eating beef and the pushes to
ban the consumption of beef because
Hindus worship the cow and traditionally
the job of butchering beef has gone to
Muslims but you know it's one of these
things where they're using these the
accusation of defeating much the way
blasphemy is being used in Pakistan so
if you don't like what your next-door
neighbor is doing or you have a property
dispute you can simply claim blasphemy
and you've got a mob to take care of
them for you similarly their lynching
Muslim kids in India with very little
evidence yeah I think we don't hear that
much about that even the idea here when
you say the phrase Hindu extremists it
almost doesn't even sound like something
that would make sense for the average
Westerner to put together it's a good
question you know I think we're so
careful about wanting to be politically
correct that we're not always willing to
look at some of the more difficult stuff
that's coming out of cultures that we
want to believe our peace-loving and you
know getting directly to some of the
issues that you know I think about when
I hear the issues that you deal with on
your show with respect to Islam and some
of the Islamic extremism that you see I
always struggle with it a little bit
because we think of Hinduism as being
such a peaceful religion and I see the
extremes within Hinduism and I see it
targeted against the Islamic community
and so it's very hard for me to look at
the text of any one religion and say
that one in particular has a problem
this one has a text that doesn't look as
horrible
therefore we're not going to have the
same issues yeah and you know I tend to
have much more of a sense of this being
a social political issue
an economic issue a cultural issue I
have a much harder time seeing and just
coming out of the text because I see it
as coming from text that I see as being
really not that toxic within the Hindu
context mm-hmm
and we've talked about some of this
stuff privately and I've actually when
we spoke about I last time I did help me
frame a little bit about the way I you
know I try to be very careful with my
language and I don't ever certainly want
to be bigoted towards people and I want
to talk about ideas and all that but
it's nice hearing and experience you
know someone that's lived another
experience and oh maybe you're not
thinking of something in this particular
way or any of that so so we're going to
talk about the economic reasons that a
lot of this stuff happens because that's
why that's what a lot of your research
is but tell me a little bit more so
growing up in India and then you get
involved in in economics and fields that
were that were pretty and probably still
are pretty male-dominated right yes um
very what was I think you know it's
interesting it was just what I found
intellectually interesting and it was
the way my mind worked analytically and
had never occurred to me that there
would be gender issues and when I show
up in a graduate department and there
are just very few women and you know
it's changed a little bit now but
especially when I was going through it I
was at the Harvard Economics Department
and Larry Summers was actually a
professor at the department while I was
there and it wasn't until a few years
later that he ended up making comments
about why one might not see women in
technical fields as much and he had a
number of comments which got him into a
fair amount of trouble what was the
thrust of what he said um well he went
through a few different reasons he said
well it couldn't be child rearing and it
couldn't be this and it couldn't be that
and the implication was essentially that
there were intellectual differentials
between men and women and you know he
didn't say it explicitly but there was
enough there and I think my sense is
that he had probably rubbed enough
people the wrong way already by that
point that there was a desire to to push
on that but it was interesting because
when I
at this my sense is that you know I was
in the department while he was a
professor in the department and it was
very clear to me that what I was seeing
was not the straight discrimination that
he was commenting on because I think he
was pointing to the fact that he didn't
really see that kind of discrimination
and I would agree with him I don't think
that's what the problem was I think the
problem as I saw it was much more that
the female temperament is very different
than a male temperament and there tends
to be much more of a focus amongst women
towards building networks and building
relationships and if you think about the
fact that evolutionarily women have had
the job of kin work and men have had to
be more alpha and be aggressive and be
competitive it sort of makes sense that
this is the temperament that we're
bringing and men are bringing a much
more alpha temperament so you know from
the beginning I'd see the men sitting
around comparing what questions people
as how many different graduate programs
they had gotten to amongst the top
programs who was going to win the first
Nobel Prize and the women had this
different approach of let's work
together let's do our problem sets
together how do we encourage each other
but I really have to wonder then how
much of the end result in terms of the
differences that we see is an issue of
our of male-dominated fields really not
being as open to a female approach to
doing things and sort of you know a less
competitive less aggressive with
inserting yourself yeah I assume you can
see pros and cons to both of that on one
hand the competitive side perhaps of the
men go and you know how many you know
graduate students you get into this so
competition is good on the other hand
working together is also good absolutely
absolutely and you know clearly you want
to be able to encourage the risk-taking
that I think men are better at because
women tend to have a need to really
deliver on what they promised
probably because if you look at the
roles we've traditionally taken on as
homemakers mother as caregivers there is
a need for consistency and if you look
at what men are do
there's often a need for greater risk
taking because if you don't shoot for
something that you might not be able to
hit you're not necessarily going to be
able to achieve as much I believe
they're both really important but I
think where we are now is that we're in
a situation where we are so focused on
one end of the skill spectrum that we
are not necessarily incorporating some
of the other values that we want to be
bringing into the workforce and you know
this leads to so meaning what that we're
so focused on just results in or on risk
taking on competitiveness and you know I
do think if we get into some of the
diversity issues which I assume we will
at some point I think that just in terms
of greed one needs to be thinking about
how do we tap into the great resource
that women have to offer us if you think
about the fact that out of nine hundred
odd Nobel prizes less than 50 have gone
to women you've got to imagine that
that's some huge set of resources that
we're not tapping into sufficiently and
then the question is how do we build up
these resources so that we actually do
access the analytic abilities that women
are able to bring to the table even if
they don't have as much of the
temperament necessarily yeah tell me a
little bit more about your mind because
you meant you said I think my mind
always worked that way or that was what
my mind was always attracted to was
economics what does that mean so like
you're 15
like did you think you know like you
really cared about this kind of stuff I
really did so when I was very young my
father used to do some nonprofit work on
family planning so he had his regular
business but he was this was what he was
doing philanthropically and I remember
sitting at the dining table talking
about the issue of population growth and
how do we actually think about it was
the first time that I started thinking
in terms of opportunity costs so it
turns out the best way to reduce
population growth is to educate women so
that they have a higher opportunity cost
of having children and you see this
happening
naturally as countries develop but to
the extent that you can encourage it
it's one of the most effective ways of
increasing birth control and increasing
improving family planning and you know
just a concept that if you think one
level deeper you start thinking in terms
of opportunity cause you start thinking
in terms of marginal costs on just the
entire sort of economic toolkit and how
that leads you to think about incentives
was very much the way my mind worked
that's interesting so then you got your
doctorate in economics at Harvard you
say Harvard people get all these it's
almost like it's become like Hogwarts in
a weird way you know being like people
think it's like this this mythical place
what was it like for you there or what
if you had to just describe Harvard
because I just feel like it just has
this connotations attached to it that
people don't associate with other
colleges it's like an other thing
altogether well that's interesting I
sort of see where it comes from
if nothing else because they have access
to such an impressive application poor
applicant pool that the people they let
in you're in an environment which is
very intellectually alive so you know
some of the best conversations I've ever
had was sitting around the dining table
of friends when I was in graduate school
because just the level of discourse is
so exposed and conscious of what's going
on in the world an erudite and you just
you can just tap into a different level
of conversation you know sitting in a
cafe in Harvard Square you hear
conversations all around you which are
fascinating that being said my actual
experience within the Economics
Department was considerably less present
kind of dumb and I remember someone
saying to me that if you're not
depressed in graduate school you're not
doing it correctly but it really was
quite extreme I ran into it is that
mostly because of the workload er
because it was that did that have
something to do with being a woman in a
male-dominated field or just oh honey
that was part of it I think a big part
of it was when I started working on my
dissertation I ran up again
and some of the deep cultural issues
that economics faces and I think I
really wasn't ready for it I think I was
somewhat oblivious to just what happens
within mainstream economics departments
and how constrained one is in terms of
how one is able to think and what one is
allowed to talk about and this seems to
be a trend in a lot of the things that I
talk about on this show about what you
can talk about what you can't talk about
how you will be treated if you talk
about things that you know people don't
want you to talk about that's right and
you know this is why working at I net
for me has been such a revelation
because I was really interested in the
heterodox economics and there really
wasn't a community back then and it's
only post 2008 since the creation of AI
net that I feel like we just have this
ability to gather heterodox economists
from everywhere so that we actually
believe that there enough of us that
there's a community that we have the
freedom to be able to to think and talk
about the sort of stuff amongst our
community which has been just really
wonderful there's that community thing
again so it does have some value all
right yes so now let's get into some
some economic sure I thought to start a
conversation about economics I took econ
101 a long time ago didn't do
particularly well math in general is not
my thing I like the social sciences more
for my audience that's watching it
really doesn't care particularly about
economics or know that much but two
little theories can we do some like
basic economics if someone's as you what
what is economics yeah sure so my kids
ask me this and one thing that I always
say to them is try not to think about
economics as a study of money because
that's really the most limited and
probably incorrect way of thinking about
it it's really the study of incentives
and when you think about you know the
two concepts that I mentioned earlier I
think really drive my understanding of
the field the concept of opportunity
cost and the concept of thinking and
marginal terms so once you understand
diminishing marginal utility for example
how every additional unit is a good that
you consume it means just that much
less to you so you know these are very
simple concepts but defined so much of
how we actually behave in the world and
you know one of the ways that I've
talked about it is that you can think of
what's really fascinating about the
subject to me is that you can start with
five very simple assumptions on human
behavior you can assume that you have
rational human beings you have perfect
information that you have freedom of
entry and exit you know five very simple
assumptions you can make and something
miraculous happens which is that it
allows you to tap into an entire world
of mathematics which you can then impose
on human behavior and you can set up
models so that you can actually try to
understand how people will behave and
you can understand how markets will
behave based on individual behavior and
there's something really amazing about
the idea that you can take something as
messy as human behavior and link it to
something as pure as mathematics and
actually get an understanding of how our
world works yeah which is the thing that
I found really amazing the problem with
that is that these assumptions because
they're so simple don't quite capture
human behavior sufficiently and it gets
you to the point where you can create
models that capture some things very
effectively but also lead you down some
paths that are probably not correct and
it also very interestingly ends up
leading you toward certain political
orientations and it's interesting how a
mathematical framework sort of pushes
you politically towards a particular
direction but what it really does is
that it holds up the idea of efficiency
above everything else because what
you're trying to do then is you're
trying to maximize efficiency that is
what economists hold is the holy grail
and so then we get very focused on this
concept of efficiency and it turns out
that there's sort of a trade-off between
efficiency and
on distribution equality inequality and
because these economies get so caught up
in the beauty of what it takes to get
efficiency we lose track of the other
side of this and so while I started off
being fascinated by what we call the
neoclassical model which is just this
very simple form of economics that you
get from thinking and marginal terms and
being a being able to apply calculus
because we're thinking in marginal terms
to starting to try and understand what
are the assumptions that maybe we are
not in a position to make where are we
going wrong what are some of the other
things that we need to bring in and you
know that leads you to an entirely
different way of thinking about the
economy and this is why I had talks
economics is so much more interesting to
me now interesting so it's funny I'm
always very upfront with my audience
there are certain guests that I try to
do a little less research with because I
want to go in with sort of a really
blank slate and ask sort of the simpler
questions there are some guess that I
have to do a little more research on or
know a specific quote or a chronology of
something and for you you definitely for
me we're one of the people that had to
do more research on and read more of the
stuff that you've done because I wanted
to have a handle on it enough to ask the
right questions so you wrote a really
interesting piece on the economics of
despair and I read it now three or four
times actually and I thought it does sum
up so much of what's happening right now
in the political system it shows to me
it shows the the truth true through line
between economics and politics so first
off can you can you recap with the with
the piece why sure so this was actually
really interesting to me because about
15 20 years ago I was looking at Russia
post collapse of the Soviet Union and
what we were finding was that there was
a mortality crisis death rates amongst
middle-aged white men were rising
dramatically and when we started looking
at what the causes were it was
essentially people drinking themselves
to
because their lives had suddenly become
so uncertain their economy had collapsed
they had no idea how to transition to
this new way of being and they were just
lost and so you know heart attacks were
on the rise
alcohol poisoning was on the rise and it
was very much the sense that these were
deaths of despair and I hadn't looked to
that work for a long time and then
recently on to Princeton economist Angus
Deaton and on case came out with some
research looking at how mortality is
actually starting to increase amongst
lower middle class white men in this
country and the more they exported it
was fascinating to me it was exactly the
same phenomena that we were seeing in
Russia post collapse of the Soviet Union
and you know it's what they have termed
debts of despair the opioid epidemic
alcohol suicides heart attacks and it's
really the burden is falling amongst
whites with a high school education or
lower and so then the question is what
is causing this and to me this was
linking directly with some of the other
stuff that we have been talking about
with respect to politics with this
question of what's happening in Rust
Belt America yeah what is the sudden
rise in populist immuno the word I hear
more often than any other now is
populism and you know what is driving
this where is this coming from
and if you look at what's happening to
the lives of these people you're seeing
really of collapse of an economic system
that they knew and you're seeing a
decline in wages and no ability or
thought that they can see to climbing
out of this and this tide so closely
with what I was seeing happening
politically so if you just look at some
of the numbers coming out of there in
this last election many of the counties
that voted for Obama in Wisconsin
in Michigan ended up voting for Trump in
this last election and if you look at
which counties in particular when from
Obama to Trump in so many of the cases
in a huge majority of the cases they
were counties that had voted for Bernie
Sanders and the primaries and to me this
was saying look you're seeing populism
on the Left you're seeing populism on
the right there is something that is
driving this way of thinking on both
sides of this and there is a similarity
that where somehow not understanding and
I know you've used the word economic
nationalism of fair amount in in your
talks and to me it was really this
question of when did economic
nationalism go from being a
fundamentally Democratic bastion to
something that we're hearing from the
mouths of Steve Danon and we're hearing
from Trump's people and there really is
some kind of an overlap that we're
seeing where we're seeing I think the
same issues of despair coming in the
face of globalization and the collapse
of the manufacturing sector that is
driving a lot of the politics in this
country today yeah so there's so much
there we go in a thousand different
directions yeah what strikes me
immediately is that it's sort of like
Trump had a very keen understanding of
that which is why he kept saying during
the primaries you see the way Hillary's
treating Bernie because he was trying to
give a signal to the Bernie guys going
even once she takes him out which she
was going to do one way or another I'm
your guy not her so do you think he
really had an awareness of that sort of
at the economic level or was that just
sort of realpolitik in his mind do you
think I know I know you're not a Trump
psychiatrist I'm not a Trump
psychiatrist do you take a lot of money
is it from psychiatrist now can you
touch that one I think that it was
increasingly clear to a lot of people
who were looking at this that the
rank-and-file
of the Democratic Party was very very
disillusioned with what we were seeing
coming from them and you know there's
another whole area that I would want to
talk about which is the
investment theory of party competition
that was developed by Tom Ferguson and
some of my colleagues where the idea is
really that at some point it became so
expensive to run a campaign that the
only way to do it was to get a
tremendous amount of money in from
corporate America the billionaire class
and I think that really changed the
conversation that was happening within
the Democratic Party I think it has been
very much the conversation that's been
happening in the Republican Party for a
long time and I think Bernie was able to
tap into something and I think Trump
understood very clearly that there was
this populist rising he was able to tap
into it too now I will say that even
though a lot of the Trump counties sorry
the Obama counties that went for Trump
or Bernie supporters there was another
statistic that I found fascinating which
was that in Michigan there were
apparently 80,000 ballots that people
had filled out where they had filled out
both sides of the ballot and they had
left the space for president blank and
to me this is a very strong indication
if you think about the fact that Trump
won Michigan by 10,000 votes
we're talking about $80,000 this is a
very strong indication that this was
people who were just really fed up with
what they see happening at the
conversation with both these parties
here they just have a sense of none of
this is real and my sense about it is
that they're actually correct and when I
hear liberal economists talk about what
happened in the wake of the election I'm
hearing a fair amount of stuff which
talks about akhada what was it the other
day I heard someone on de marsay the
knuckle-dragging Midwestern or is it
something like this and you know there
was just this idea they had been had
Trump promised them something he's never
going to give them things that he
promised you know for all I know that
may be true I don't know that he's
actually going to come through and you
know if you ask me I'd say it's probably
unlikely that he'd come through on some
of his more nationalist promises I think
trade and immigration or the first you
know immigration he may actually
push hard on but with respect to trade I
think there's just too much political
support and financial support that he's
going to get that pushes him away from
his economic nationalist arguments but I
think it was very clear that the people
who were reacting this way were just
sick of the VISAA were coming from both
sides with respect to real economic
issues with respect to trade with
respect to immigration with respect to
financial globalization just all of
these things which have really been very
bad for lower middle class America these
people in the Rust Belt they were losing
their jobs and watching their way of
life disappear they're going for
anything so in some ways you had Bernie
supporters that voted for Trump even
though economic policies were hugely
different but you're just grasping for
anything that that kind of makes sense
so when you hear a liberal economist in
this case I'm not sure who it was on
Bill Maher but when you hear this person
talk about these knuckle-draggers or
whatever isn't that also it's almost
feeding into that thing again like these
people are so sick and tired of being
abused and beaten and ridiculed by the
system that even if that guy is right
whoever this person is that they're
still doing the very thing that pushes
people to vote potentially what could be
for against their interests absolutely
and I think this is this was one of the
genius parts of Trump's campaign where
he actually understood that he needed to
bring a different level of respect to
the real issues that these people were
facing I think Bernie did it and I think
my sense is that Bernie actually would
have come through on a lot of these
promises but you know for campaign
finance reasons various other reasons he
couldn't push past the Hillary machine
it you know would have been a much more
interesting contest if it was Bernie
against Trump but you know regardless of
whether or not Trump actually comes
through on any of these promises I think
he's already giving these people a lot
of what they're looking for just in
terms of respect for their ideas and
some acknowledgment that what they're
saying and what they're seeing is real
which I believe we as liberal economist
have not really come through on yeah
because then you're just saying the
saying you know they get belittled and
then
you're saying I see you bunch of morons
you're you're getting exactly what you
sowed and it's like well that's not
going to help them come to your side how
much of this do you think is just that
systems just get to this place where
this happened you know anyway like so in
the rest of the jobs that are going away
it's like any other thing that exists
for a certain amount of time and it
doesn't that there's pride oh no is
there an example in history when when a
whole industry started disappearing but
everyone figured out the way to get out
properly is there any example of that
that you can think of where it was
prepared for people because they
realized that one thing was going away
and something they were going to have to
do something else or is this just the
natural order of things it may be and
you know one of the things that I'm
really interested now we recently moved
from New York to Silicon Valley and so
one of the lines of research that I have
been following is someone in Peter
Turman and MIT economists just came out
with this book where he talks about the
dual economy and the dying middle class
of America and he points out that while
we are very focused on the notion of
secular stagnation and how we're not
seeing sufficient growth in the economy
and we're really seeing a stagnation of
real wages especially in especially with
manufacturing sector but what he does
point to is that there is one sector of
the economy that or three sectors of the
economy that have traditionally been
doing really well which is finance
technology and electronics and so even
though much of our focus has been on
secular stagnation we really are doing
well in areas of innovation and areas of
finance in the question for us then is
how do we actually take lessons from
this area and try to bring it to the
rest of the economy more importantly how
do we try to smooth the part of the rest
of the economy so that we can make this
a lot less painful than it might
otherwise be and you know one of the
things that one here is a lot in Silicon
Valley is how do we bring new ideas to
this why don't we start thinking in
terms of basic income because we are
going to be disrupting the job market at
some very serious level we need to make
sure everyone's taken care of
left-left and economists tend to be very
suspicious with the notion of basic
income because the fear is that we're
going to use this to basically upend our
current welfare systems and if we decide
we're going to give everyone ten
thousand a year and then we're going to
forget about them that's probably not
going to do what we wanted to do so it's
really a question of how do we approach
something like basic income so we make
sure we are taking care of the people
that whose lives were disrupting but
regardless you know we are going to see
this huge change in the nature of jobs
in this country and we need to be
getting ahead of this to try and think
about how do we address it and you know
part of it is that we need to think
about how our companies structured
importa the incentive structure is to
the extent that maximizing shareholder
value has been the driving push for many
American corporations we're going to
find incentives built in that are going
to want to encourage globalization and
marginalize workers who are lower down
on the income scale because that's what
improves shareholder value so if we
change some of the incentive structures
around this I do think there's a lot we
can do to actually smooth the transition
but eventually I do think you're right
we're going to see these changes and
it's a question of how do we get ahead
of them yeah it's interesting because a
couple weeks ago I had dr. Mike Munger
from Duke University who's in a
political science professor at Duke or
he's in charge of the the politics
philosophy department I think it's
politic philosophy and Economics
Department and and he's more of a
libertarian but he was making a sort of
libertarian argument for universal basic
income and I've never heard it described
Aliza that I always would have thought
that left-leaning
economists would have been for it but
it's interesting that you're saying not
necessarily and and he was actually
making a libertarian argument for
universal they had income so there is a
lot of room to come together with people
of different thinking traditionally in
this regard absolutely which is
something that I you know I really hope
to be able to do now how do we bring
some new economic thinking to the
innovations that we're seeing coming out
of Silicon Valley you know I think basic
income is a
disruptive idea but I really do think we
need to play with it and we need to try
and take it on in a way that we aren't
co-opting welfare systems and you know
make sure that we're not using it to
actually disenfranchise you wanted it to
completely co-opt welfare so his
argument was that the welfare systems
are failing so let's do this with that
money but I can see why well the
question is why both arguments have
merit well the question is are you
really going to do this with this money
are you going to really try and bring in
the disenfranchised and make sure that
they're properly taken care of what are
you going to set your basic income at
you know how are you going to ensure
transition out of it once people go into
the workforce how are you thinking about
you know my point on this is that we
really need to be thinking about the
economics of it when we structure it I
am not against the idea of universal
basic income I think it may be a
solution to actually handle the fact
that we're going to be seeing a
tremendous amount of disruption in our
job market but we really need to think
about how we're implementing it and how
much how much resource we're going to be
willing to put into this and you know
it's interesting because in Silicon
Valley people really think in terms of
an abundance economy on the East Coast
people still think in terms of scarcity
with capital s small s you know the
notion of economics is built around the
idea of scarcity and you really do have
the ability I think to use some of
what's coming out of Silicon Valley to
start rethinking some of our fundamental
economic notions has automation and
machines and robots and drones and all
that completely change the discussion I
mean are the discussions that economists
are having now widely different than
they were having even five years ago
even though it was obvious that we were
trending in this direction has it just
completely altered the landscape I think
the problem is that it hasn't and I
think it has really I think it's coming
and you know people will do analyses of
how much of the destruction of the
manufacturing sector is coming as a
result of trade as a result of
immigration how much of it is automation
so you know these are the three things
people talk about and it's like you know
what part of it is globalization what
part of it is automation
I don't think we're thinking in terms of
how do we get ahead of this what how do
we need to change the conversation
because eventually this is coming and
what do we do to position ourselves for
when it comes yeah yeah they're very so
interesting to me that it's not being
discussed as much as you think because
there's so many people in Silicon Valley
especially that are like guys this is
this is the game changer I mean there's
so many things that I think are game
changes if you look at just what's
happening with cryptocurrencies you know
I think it's really going to change the
nature of transactions of macroeconomics
and I think we need to be coming up with
new economics to think about that as
well
so I think there's a lot of things that
we're going to have to be thinking about
differently underlying it although I
think one does need you know going back
to the earlier point I think underlying
all of this is going to be incentives
and we really need to think about how do
we build the correct incentives in so
that we're taking care of people through
this entire process so with all this in
mind the politics at its core does it
really just come down to economics I
would imagine as an economist and us
probably want to believe that but the
more I talk to economists and think
about this stuff I mean the idea of if
you've got a job and you you know then
you can afford to hopefully have a home
whether you're owning it or renting it
and you can put some food on the table
and that that basically takes care of
90% of what we talked about in the
political scheme of things I think it's
true I did warn you that from the age of
15 this was the way of you and well
don't ask me that's going to be the
answer I get but I actually do think
there's more actually man change we want
you to learn a little bit about learn do
it well you know I have because I think
what I'm coming to realize if I look at
what we're what our current political
situation is and I see the role that
identity politics is taking in our
society I do have the sense that the
heart of identity politics is or the
driving force is really coming from the
economics as well so you know I talked a
little bit earlier about the investment
theory of party competition and just how
campaigns
finance changed everything and you know
it's become increasingly clear that
money drives elections in a way that we
never really have acknowledged so you
know recent studies done by some of my
colleagues will show that there's almost
a one-to-one correspondence between the
amount of money spent on a congressional
race and whether or not and who wins
that congressional race and if it's
really money that's driving it then you
would imagine that politicians are going
to have to raise a certain amount of
money which they can't really do with
small donations anymore so as much as we
heard about how Obama raised money
through small donations if you actually
look at what was driving his campaign
especially the second time around there
was a lot of really big corporate
finance in there and if you think about
what that does from the incentive
structure of politicians when they're in
power there is very quickly it becomes
really expensive to actually come
through on the economic nationalism that
the Democrats traditionally promised
their base so if you can't actually give
them the economic things that you've
promised them well identity politics is
a really inexpensive way to feed them
and you know my sense was with watching
the increase of this conversation in our
society is that this is really a
distraction this is a way to take
people's focus away from the fact that
they're really unhappy about what's
happening economically and say let's
give you something else to focus on and
you know I think it sort of drew up for
the Democrats this time um and it's
blown up in a way where I think the
identity politics has gotten really
toxic and the economic issues aren't
being addressed either so you know I
really think I'm waiting until the
Democratic Party finally wakes up and
understands that they're just not going
to be able to get away with substituting
identity politics for the real economics
that they need to be providing their
base in a weird way does that almost
seem too late like they've traded in it
for too long
that even though I would suspect some of
the party heads or the consultants that
they bring in or even the economists
that they bring in are probably going
guys this is the losing game here but
you're sort of in so deep how would you
then publicly put a face on that to be
like we got to change what we're doing
here it's tough I mean I think they're
rattling with that right now I think
they're grappling with that you know one
of the problems is that you say the even
the economists they bring in the one
thing I found economists to be
particularly weak at is looking at their
own incentive structures so the phrase
that my co-author and I have coined is
the economics of economics who's
actually going to look at the incentive
structure at the Economist and if I look
at the economics that was coming out
before this last election economists
know that free trade increasing trade
liberalisation is going to come with a
redistributed consequence and they know
that the target the burden is going to
fall very specifically on a particular
group of people so if you look at what
happened with NAFTA NAFTA had efficiency
effects that were positive but they were
really small compared to the
redistributed effects and in particular
the effects on very specific segments of
population geographically and in terms
of particular manufacturing sectors and
it can't and the economists working for
the Democratic Party very often were
whitewashing this they weren't being
honest about what they knew would the
redistributed effects of Trade and as a
result my sense is that you've got the
system feeding each other is feeding
itself where you know the politicians
are looking for a particular kind of
economics the economists are happy to
feed that to them because that's what's
going to write their paychecks yeah and
so you know no one's willing to actually
stand out and say hey there's a problem
and you know Bernie Sanders actually did
and he had a few economists who actually
came up with his economic plans that
said you know we can make this work and
the backlash among mainstream economists
was huge very few people were really
willing to take seriously some very
serious economic
if it went into these stands and say
yeah there's there's a real point here
there's something workable here so you
know I really think underlying a lot of
this once again is incentives and in
this case I think the incentives that
economy really economist studying the
economy have their own incentive
structure and you actually recall I was
studying the economy you know I think
this came to light very strongly with
the 2008 financial crash where I think
we you know the Queen of England
apparently walked into an investment
bank and had one question for the
economists there why didn't we see this
coming and you know that simple question
I think has been something that has
driven many of us in the last several
years to say where did we go wrong as
economist and it's really interesting
that economists have been so hesitant to
look at their own incentive structures
in this that that's so interesting to me
because I remember before the crash I
remember being at a bar with a friend of
mine who worked for Lehman Brothers
uh-huh
and he was talking to another guy and it
was my friend Chris and he kept saying
this thing is going to be a disaster
you have no I like I remember and I had
no I don't even know that I had heard
about it before or realized that there
were any problems even I don't know if I
just wasn't paying attention to that
sector saying but it's so interesting
that that some people knew some people
didn't some people were going to profit
off of the disaster some you know that
all of those competing interests just
lead us to that's right and then you
look at where it leads us to with the
political interest so if you look at
what happened after the crash and once
Obama was in office it turns out that
you know a lot of the mortgages that
underlay the crisis were really badly
constructed so they really didn't have
even the legal grounds for the banks to
be able to push on foreclosures and so
had the Obama administration chosen to
come down hard on the banks and force
them to negotiate they could have really
prevented a lot of this foreclosure
foreclosure crisis and you know one of
my one of the things I say today is the
Trump is really a symptom of the
problems within the Democratic Party
because I think there was such a
backlash
was so disillusioned with Obama at the
end of what we saw with the resolution
of this crisis yes we got growth rates
back up but if you look at what a burden
the housing crisis placed on Main Street
America because he really wasn't willing
to go after Wall Street I think it
becomes very clear where this
disillusionment is coming from and you
know once again why wasn't he willing to
go after Wall Street well take a look at
where some of those campaign finance
funds came from so is that sort of the
biggest issue with Obama than that he
was a - you know forget after the crowd
go fast forward - after the crash he was
a two-term president he could have done
things about campaign finance or at
least talked about it more or I remember
sort of even at the end his last few
months when he was a lame-duck he'd
still be headlining $30,000 a head plate
then saying that the Republicans only
care about money money money and it's
like well you had an opportunity to do
something and I by the way I don't even
regret him any of that because they all
do the same freaking thing and a
Republican would have done it too but at
that point he wasn't running for
re-election and perhaps that even hurt
Hillary in some regard oh there's no
question I mean what was Hillary doing
with those goldman sachs talks right I
mean none of this made any sense but
yeah just rewind to 2010 where you know
he didn't do so well in the
congressional elections he realized that
people were really angry about a segment
of the year they got they got banged up
exactly and he realized just because
people were really angry that no one had
actually paid for this financial crisis
you know bonuses actually went up that
year on Wall Street as opposed to going
down and you know Obama was apparently
shocked that bonuses on Wall Street had
gone up he had the chance to do
something about it he came out with the
Volcker Rule in 2010 but it was so
watered down that even Paul Volcker was
shocked because it really didn't stop
banks from involving themselves with
hedge funds and all of other stuff that
got us to the too-big-to-fail yes there
was so much that could have been done to
actually change our financial economy so
that we do not have to deal with this
kind of crisis in the future and he
didn't do it and then you know again you
just have to ask what with what was
Center structure hmm so one of the
things people ask me so people always
say you know why are you liberal why do
you still call yourself a liberal you
sound like a libertarian and I always
try to lay out my liberal cred but I do
say I think if I were 90% of the things
that I believe I haven't moved at all
and I would argue that the left has
moved left and I stayed here I do think
I've shifted a little bit right
economically when it comes to taxes
particularly now that I'm a small
business owner and have employees and
things like that when you hear someone
say that there are four small taxes and
small business and all of those things
as a left-leaning economist is there
something that I could be missing in in
this regard
um I think my strongest feeling about
this is if I look at some of the
rent-seeking behavior that I believe
drives a lot of how things are
structured institutionally within this
country I see policies where you have
the billionaire class that has a certain
incentive structure that very often is
going to take from the millionaire class
and those below and they're perfectly
willing to redistribute to the bottom
end of the spectrum as long as it
doesn't touch them so you know it's one
thing to talk about taxes on small
business owners it's another thing to
talk about carried interest right and
it's these questions that we really are
not going to be allowed to touch because
the arm the forces behind wanting to
hold those in place are so powerful
financially and economically yeah so in
my specific instance as a small business
owner you don't have an issue with small
taxes or low taxes and you know I mean
we have a progressive tax system I think
it's really important to me that we have
a progressive tax system you know I
think what we really need to be thinking
about is in equality in this country if
you look at the fact that in the 1970s
the top 1% had something like 10 percent
of the income and it's gone up now to 20
percent of the income the point 1
percent of the economy of our population
is earning 8 times as much as it
we've gone completely crazy with respect
to inequality and I don't think the
problem is the middle class it really is
the billionaire class and you know the
huge distinction we're seeing I think
that's where we need to be looking at
yeah well if I want to put in emphasis
my small business magnate billionaire
class but you know I think this goes
further I think when we think about the
issue of globalization as well we should
be very clear about the fact that
globalization has had very positive
consequences for the developing world so
China was able to raise a tremendous
amount of the number of people out of
poverty because they were able to open
up their manufacturing sector to the
west and the only problem with that is
that we are doing good in terms of
poverty at absolute levels across the
world but who is bearing the brunt of it
it's not the richest people in this
country who are the ones who are all for
free trade it's the lower middle class
and my feeling is you know if you're
willing to actually redistribute your
income that's fine what really bothers
me is that you want policies that you
say are going to help the rest of the
world that are going to fall on the
backs of the lower middle class in this
country yeah all right so we have about
ten minutes left
okay I want to talk about a guy that we
both know for just a moment
have you heard of this Eric Weinstein
fella you know this guy that I'm talking
yeah I tend to hang out with him a fair
match so you are married to Eric
Weinstein putting a side marriage for
just a sec I won't go too deep into your
into your personal marriage but you guys
have done work together I mean real work
together you coming at it really from
from an economists point of view him
coming at it from a mathematical point
of view and you've sort of married these
these two ideas so can you I guess time
that you know what before we get into
pull it up well first off what's it like
working with someone or tell me how you
met actually I know a little bit I know
a little bit about it I'm asking 17
questions they want a little bit about
how you met how you started working
together and then what actually guys
came up with yeah we are saying we have
to come up with a better meeting story
yeah he was cruising women's clothes he
came for one party at my undergraduate
college and that was it yeah yeah and
you know working together was really
interesting because on the one hand it
can be very very challenging on the
other hand you really get to know
someone at a different level than you
could ever imagine because you're
functioning in this very very abstract
space where I found that each of us was
bringing our own intuition honed in a
very different context so that sometimes
he'd say something that I'd know just
intuitively from understanding the
economics couldn't be correct and
sometimes I'd say something that he'd
know couldn't be correct from the math
but you know we were in very very
abstract space when we were talking
about this you really get to see the
inner workings of someone's mind in a
way that's really incredible and it's
something that I'm so glad we were able
to do and you know we still talk about
many issues together we're not working
as much on the technical stuff now yeah
but let's talk a little bit about the
technical stuff sure so he and I worked
together on a project where we were
using gauge theory which is a kind of
calculus to look at some issues and
economics and so when I talked a little
bit earlier about how economics allows
you to bring a physics metric to looking
at humans it can but the problem is
sometimes the math we use is limited
enough that it's forced economists to
make some very unwell incorrect
assumptions so the case that we were
working on was where we were looking at
measures of the economy so the Consumer
Price Index or GDP measures so measuring
inflation or growth and what we found
was that the assumption that economists
had placed was that we have to assume
the preferences don't change in order
for us to actually be able to come up
with an index that makes sense and it
turns out that if you're working with
standard
Julis it is very hard to do an index
number that allows you to have changing
preferences but if you shift to use
engage theory in fact you can develop an
index which comes close to well which
actually accurately keeps track of an
individual's utility so the actual the
actual growth in a person's consumption
basket or what the actual inflation is
that a person experiences given the
basket that they were consuming so you
know when it was very very interesting
work theoretically and then it had this
very strong real-world application the
problem was the timing was just really
bad because we were working on issues of
inflation right about the time that two
senators backed backward and Moynihan
had put together Commission to try and
adjust the way we calculate CPI and it
was really interesting how this thing
came about because what they realized
was that Social Security was going to be
in trouble and they wanted a way to cut
back on Social Security but it's very
clear that Social Security is a third
rail right you cannot touch it because
politically it's suicide so they figured
out this ingenious backdoor where they
said if we point out that the Consumer
Price Index is actually overvalued that
the way we're calculating it is
incorrect and we scaled it back and
specifically if we scale it back by
saying that we have we are
miscalculating by 1.1 percent we can
save a trillion dollars over ten years
so they got a group of economists
together with the hope that they would
find that the CPI was in fact overvalued
and it just so happened that one of the
people on this commission two of the
people on this commission were the
Harvard Economics Department right when
I was writing my thesis and you know I
was this naive graduate student and I
would walk into real Jorgensen's office
and say guess what I've got this great
way to calculate the CPI and he took one
look at the same he say
you got nothing get out of here and you
I ended up working with Eric Maskin who
later won a Nobel Prize for a more
theoretical work and he loved it and
then he met with it with Dale Jorgenson
and then came back and said no it's not
going to work and you know when I talk
about the economics of economics and I
talk about the incentive structures of
economists to me this was really
initiation by fire very quickly how the
field actually works and what is driving
academic knowledge within this field
yeah boy there's so much richness there
I feel that we should go personal for
the for the last questionnaire because
we can talk to economic theory all day
long so what is it like to be I mean you
guys are sort of an intellectual
powerhouse couple that's got a that's
got to be kind of interesting you must
meet all sorts of interesting people
constantly be having those those
discussions how do you remain normal
people I mean we've got to know each
other now and have had dinners and
things I mean how do you you know just
not how do you get out of that world
together sometimes I don't know we go
hiking we go swimming we go biking we're
normal people that we have really
interesting dinner table conversations
so it's it's just what life is eating
we're having dinner tonight so you guys
so looking forward it's going to be a
really interesting dinner conversation
well it's been an absolute pleasure
talking yeah I'm glad we finally did
this and you know I realized that you've
got on Twitter just in the last leg
hours or something do you even know what
your Twitter name is I think it's p.m.
Milani just saying I ready that's
correct
all right well if Pia is right it's just
at Pia Milani and and if not or even if
she is we're going to link down to a big
think video that she did that I think
captures a lot of what we've talked
about in some stuff that we didn't quite
get to and thanks for watching we'll do
it again next week
[Music]
you